the verdict reads as follows we the jury
find the defendant Steven Avery guilty
of first-degree intentional homicide
his eyes are starting to kind of welling
up and he's looking over towards the
jury and shaking his head and you know
all I could think of was you know what
must be going through his mind at that
moment thinking oh my god
not again I like I can't believe this is
happening to me again the Netflix
documentary series making a murderer
became a national sensation after it
aired last year and it's been lighting
up the Internet ever since it tells the
story of Steven Avery and his nephew
Brendan Dassey who were tried in 2007
for the murder of Teresa Halbach but
nearly two decades before Avery's trial
he had been wrongfully convicted of
another heinous assault on September
11th 2003 a celebration erupted in
Manitowoc County Wisconsin as Steven
Avery walked out of the prison where he
was locked away for 18 years decried as
a monster but Avery was suing police and
prosecutors for misconduct giving
Manitowoc County 36 million reasons not
to forget him so when 25 year old
photographer Teresa Halbach went missing
during the lawsuit the police may have
had a familiar suspect in mind Avery's
attorneys jerry buting and Dean Strang
won over viewers with their principled
and hard-fought defense in the murder
trial
they are currently touring
internationally hoping to further the
discussion started by the documentary
reason TV sat down with jerry buting to
talk about the Avery and Dassey cases
updates since the documentary series
aired and what the cases reveal about
the criminal justice system at the end
of the day do you believe that Steven
Avery is innocent I do I do but what I
believe doesn't really matter because
I'm just I'm his lawyer I'm his advocate
I wasn't there nobody but God knows at
this point but you know I've been at
this long enough when I look at the
evidence I never bought the state's case
none of it ever made sense to me and
there was certainly reasonable doubt I
thought that we presented at trial you
know he had no motive he was going to
get a four hundred thousand dollar
tax-free check from that was already on
the governor's desk
as he was going to get within a matter
of days separate above his 36 million
dollar lawsuit and then when we started
digging into the evidence what a little
evidence there was that pointed to his
guilt look so suspicious that you know
it just really became very questionable
in my mind not only that that he was
innocent but that there was some
manipulation of the evidence that was
going on by somebody though much of the
film cast doubt on Avery's guilt at no
point did the filmmakers or the defense
propose an alternative theory about who
killed Teresa Halbach so why weren't you
able to present any other suspects in
the trial well there's a rule of law
that a lot of states have to sort of
limit for defendants just trying to blow
smoke confuse a jury but it was never
required until this case that you also
the defense also be required to prove
the motive of the third party so
basically you have to prove motive if
you want to introduce that but the state
they're allowed to give an alternative
theory like Ken Kratz did basically
saying that you have to believe if
you're the jury that the police did this
if your delete the defense are you as
the jury in order to find mr. Avery not
guilty willing to say that your cops
killed her mutilated her burned her
bones all to set up and to frame mr.
Avery you've got to be willing to say it
you've got to make that leap the thing
that's so unfair and imbalance here is
that the prosecutor who has the full
burden beyond a reasonable doubt never
has to prove motive and yet to say that
the defense would have to prove the why
it's in Congress in my mind also very
difficult particularly this case from
the beginning their focus of their
investigation was only on Steven Avery
and they you know they failed to check
out alibis of those other people in her
life that were close to her the kind of
investigation that might have revealed a
motive how are we supposed to know that
they won't talk to us there you know and
the police didn't investigate and so in
terms of those alternative theories you
said you don't want to speculate about
that or talk about that outside of a
courtroom have you been following the
speculation on on Reddit there's you
know troves of information I've seen
some of it yes
I mean there's some there's some kind of
crazy theories on reddit there's some
not so not so crazy some some pretty
interesting theories have you seen your
theory that you wanted to present in
court online somewhere some of it yes
but we were stopped by the judges
rulings in a stunning twist in the case
Steven Avery 16 year old learning
disabled nephew Brendan Dassey
implicated himself in the murder after
police pulled him out of school and
questioned him for hours without a
lawyer or his mother present his alleged
confession seemed to cement the state's
case against Steven Avery and though he
almost immediately recanted it it sent
the teenager to prison for life one
thing that I hear from people that watch
the documentary they say that's not sure
whether Steven Avery is guilty or not I
don't think he got a fair trial though
but when they look at Brendan Dassey
they say boy this kid
there's just no no evidence we really
think he's innocent and yet he's
convicted and the reason that they think
that is because they actually get to see
what his interview was like here's a guy
who's just confessed apparently to this
horrible heinous murder and rape and a
total lack of recognition of what he's
just said do you think I can get there
before 1:29 um probably not
what's that 1:29 well I have a project
doing six oh now okay are you no I need
to see WrestleMania tonight I mean you
know obviously a young man with with
some limitations so it takes some skill
and experience to present false
confession case to a jury so that they
understand because jurors do tend to
think people won't confess falsely we
know from exoneration cases they do and
as many as twenty twenty-five percent of
the time where people are exonerated by
DNA they have confessed I'd seem to hire
for juveniles right isn't a 40 percent
yeah there's no writers right the the
younger the the more vulnerable the
suspect is the more likely it is that
they're going to make false confessions
but with that you know that evidence was
presented in court the jury apparently
didn't find it convincing it was held up
on appeal what does that say if people
can watch that and still think that
that's okay and that it was not a
coerced confession well the jury needs
to be able to see the video of the
interrogation but they also have to
understand
the techniques and the things that are
being used Brendon denied something like
75 times and yet they don't accept the
denial and you see what can happen when
you have somebody who's who's vulnerable
and suggestible I've just denied this
thing 50 70 70 times they're not
accepting it I got to give them
something that they want to hear and
then they start making suggestions about
what that might be alright I'll just
come on to ask you who shot her in the
Hat he did
why didn't tell us that second twinkle
bit now you remember it and for whatever
reason that still escapes me in
Brendan's case the very end of it the
recording is about 20 minutes the
defense stipulated with the state the
jury would not hear his mother comes in
and you know is did you do this huh not
really what do you mean not really
that's my head and the jury heard none
of that you know that might have made a
difference for them if they realize that
as soon as somebody familiar to him
comes into his life again his mother
he's immediately recanting already
ultimately the prosecution elected never
to called a see as a witness in Avery's
trial and all the charges based on his
testimony were dropped but that didn't
stop brendan dassey's alleged confession
from casting a pall over Steven Avery's
case one of the things that you
mentioned frequently about this case is
that it was very difficult to get an
impartial jury there were these press
conferences that Ken Kratz held where he
went into very graphic detail during the
rape to recess begging for help
begging 16 year-old Brendon to stop that
you can stop this
sixteen-year-old Brendon under the
instruction of Steven Avery cuts Teresa
halbachs throat but she still doesn't
die there was even a juror from the
trial who mentioned that evidence in
explaining the reasoning for his verdict
when that evidence was never presented
in court so especially now when it's so
easy to get that information you can't
just sequester people what are the
implications for jury selection you know
nowadays with social media you're right
there is even more of it probably but I
think it's really incumbent on the
judges to do a better job and sometimes
the attorneys when they're talking to
the prospective juror the juror will
start expressing some concerns and I
don't know if I can really be fair about
this and I've heard an awful lot about
this and I just don't think I can be
fair I think he's guilty for instance
and all too often a judge will then step
in and say well you understand I'm going
to instruct you that you have to put
aside any preconceived opinions you've
got and right you understand those are
going to be instructions yes and you can
follow those instructions can't you and
a leading question and injure sometimes
feel a little bit intimidated I think
and almost badgered into saying yes I
could put that aside when they really
can't Steven Avery's new lawyer for the
appeals process high-profile wrongful
conviction specialists Kathleen Zellner
recently gave a confident news week
interview and hasn't been shy on Twitter
about criticizing the trial process and
claiming she's uncovered new evidence
that could free Avery in addition to new
forensic tests zelner has cited cell
phone tower data that allegedly give him
an airtight alibi did you and Dean look
into the things that she's been
mentioning like the cell phone records
we had some records
I don't know how detailed they were
compared to what they have now and
whether the science has gotten better
with cell phone records and our cell
phone towers and pings and those sorts
of things you know so I'm not sure
exactly what she's referring to but
let's see the public will have to wait
until August 29th when zelner is
expected to file legal briefs in Avery's
appeal but the intrigue surrounding
Teresa halbachs phone doesn't end there
according to the prosecution Halbach was
last seen on the Avery property and she
made no phone calls after she stopped
there but there was evidence that some
of her voicemails were
raced after the state says she was
already dead and the police never
investigated the lead do you have any
theory about the situation with the
voicemails do we know that some were
racism or not or who might be the
singular wireless expert said it was not
full with the information they had
people who were calling in trying to
leave a message to her would not have
gotten the message the mailbox is full
and yet many of her friends say that
they called in and they were getting
that message so somehow or another there
were messages deleted whether
intentional or otherwise the other thing
the jury never heard is that there was
evidence that somebody at approximately
36 hours before she was even reported
missing to the police that somebody had
accessed her voicemail nobody ever
admitted having accessed that the judge
asked the state the prosecutor you know
do you know who did that and they ducked
the question he didn't answer does the
state know who accessed the voicemail I
suppose we if there was an inkling that
mr. buting was going to suggest that
Miss Halbach was alive at that time and
this is something they could have been
looked into investigatively so whether
they knew and never turned it over to us
I don't know according to the state she
had already been dead for you know about
36 hours or two days how was that being
done who was accessing her voicemail and
why were they erasing something somebody
who may have had a motive that he
doesn't have and somebody who may have
had opportunity was doing that alright
I'm just having trouble seeing the
apparent relevance of it at this stage
of the trial how if that somehow wasn't
relevant is still escapes me since the
documentary series aired there have been
a lot of allegations that it didn't
fairly portray the prosecutors side on
the flip side is there any evidence that
you think was not included that was
strongly exculpatory for Steven Avery
there was I think that they covered the
majority of both sides evidence that was
most in dispute but from the defense
standpoint the bones were pretty
important and maybe could have been
presented a little bit more detail
Teresa halbachs charred bones and teeth
were discovered a week after she was
reported missing in the burn pit behind
steven avery's garage crucially crow
mains were also discovered in to other
locations nearby a burn barrel outside a
neighbor's house and a quarry pile if a
jury accepted that she was burned
elsewhere then Steven Avery is innocent
and they would have had to acquit
because nobody would burn a body
somewhere off site and then bring the
remains and dump them in your own
backyard right parts of her bones from
all over her body were found in the burn
barrel which is behind the bobbie dasi
house so the one thing that was clear is
that one way or the other they removed
the site where the body was originally
burned would have had more bones that
were still connected or still in the
same orientation as in an intact body if
the bones were jumbled up it would mean
that they had been moved to that
location some of the evidence was lost
that might have told us just which was
the primary site normally investigators
would have treated the burn site like an
archaeological dig mapping out the
location of each bone to see if it had
been moved but they did no grid or
anything no grid no not even photographs
which is still boggles my mind I think
that think about no photographs at all
before they start gathering up the
evidence with shovels everything that
was collected in this area was placed
together in a box
so why would you burn her in your
backyard in the first place but if you
would why would you then start to move
her but only put a few of her bones in a
burn barrel and then leave it 100 yards
away
we presented evidence that I think was a
little more clear than the documentary
showed that it was much more likely that
her body was burned somewhere else the
burn barrel was used to scoop her up and
then dumped in the burn pit on mr.
Avery's property but a few of them were
trapped in the muck and gunk at the
bottom of the burn barrel and that's how
those bones did that's how those bones
stayed in there as a defense attorney is
it important to you that you think that
your client is innocent or does it not
matter
no I mean the the danger is when you
start making the assumption yourself of
guilt or innocence and I learned
something a long time ago back when I
was a public defender we had to open 15
new felonies a month so you started
taking shortcuts and triaging basically
you know is this an easy case that you
know is this a hard case I can't take
all of these I see this complaint and it
was a burglary as I recall open and shut
I started asking you know this is true
no no I'm Klayton completely innocent
and you know and he had this story that
was really preposterous totally
preposterous and I came back from the
office that day and was talking to some
friends and and then there's this guy
and this ridiculous story he's got and
my later to be wife picked it up and
said oh I'll take that case
I said well go ahead knock yourself out
she did he's got an investigator he was
telling the absolute truth he was
completely innocent case was dismissed
and you know I said to myself you know
what kind of a lawyer am I going to be
if I'm if I'm being the judge in the
jury and I'm making that judgment to
somebody's innocent or guilty back
quickly you know then you end up in like
the attorney in this documentary who's
before he's even met his client is
telling the police we have a 16 year old
who while morally illegally responsible
was heavily influenced you can't do that
there's one deeply affecting shot from
the documentary where right after the
verdict is
read you lean into him and whisper in
his ear what do you say to somebody in a
situation like that word they've just
found out that they're possibly going to
prison for the rest of their life you
know it's very hard that's that's the
tough part of the I hate I've only
watched that part of the documentary
once that's the most emotional time part
of it for me as well in that documentary
when you see his eyes or started kind of
welling up and he's looking over towards
the jury and shaking his head and you
know all I could think of was you know
what must be going through his mind at
that moment thinking oh my god not again
I put my faith in a jury but once before
I was wrongly convicted I spent 18 years
and now I've done it again in this case
there was so much reasonable doubt I
like I can't believe this is happening
to me again it must have been so surreal
I know that it was and very difficult
for him to deal with and and for me and
Dean to deal with is this the first
portrayal of defense attorneys as the
good guys rather than the villains or is
it historically been the other way more
often it's you know better call Saul or
sleaze balls and they unethical and for
whatever reason how I would think that
makes better drama you know and so
that's kind of image that people have
had and you know I don't think that what
Dean and I were doing is that unusual I
mean we did our job it was kind of
embarrassing her first when people were
saying you know keeping all these
accolades on us but you know at some
point it became if people want to use us
as an example of what criminal defense
lawyers are like really then fine we'll
carry that the water for that because
it's time that people do get a more
balanced view of what a good honest
criminal defense attorney with integrity
how they conduct themselves because
that's not that unusual and one of the
funny things is that you guys have kind
of become the sex symbols right and
how's your family been dealing with that
aspect of it we were in Italy when most
of the explosion of interest was
happening and after a few days my
daughter like slams shut her laptop and
discussed and I can't believe I've had
enough of this I'm and she cut off her
facebook account shut it shut it down I
said
why because all my friends are talking
about sexy jerry buting on how sexy my
father is I just grosses me out
I mean shutting down Facebook is the
nuclear option right though yeah it was
that bad
so you know when I think about it I
don't blame her or be if I was 21 I'd be
pretty weird too if you could pick a top
three takeaways from your career what
could we focus on that would really
improve the criminal justice system on
the ground if Wisconsin had not had
mandatory recordings of custodial
interrogations the public had never seen
what Brendan Dassey interview was like
and they passed that law the year before
right yes sir as part of or at least
during the Avery Commission review of
things that went wrong in the first case
of for Stephen Avery
ironically Steven Avery's arrest comes
at the same time governor Jim Doyle
plans to sign a sweeping criminal
justice reform bill inspired by Avery's
wrongful conviction a lot of state still
don't have that and in this day and age
there's no reason for that and it helps
the police in some respects too because
it protects them against claims that
defendants may make that they were being
abused or promised leniency and things
like that so that would be number one if
people want to try and do something on
their own they need to take a more
active role in what goes on in their
courthouses people in two big cities
Cleveland and Chicago just kicked out of
office these prosecutors who for years
had had been running on get tough on
crime you know clanging jail cell doors
and people are saying that's enough we
want people who are smart on crime not
just this lock them up throw away the
key thing and then if finally if you do
get a jury summons people have to take
that and enthusiastically rather than oh
my god Here I am how do I get out of
this but the reality is that that that's
a civic responsibility it's the only
direct way that people can participate
in the third branch of government the
judiciary and apply the presumption of
innocence to that defendant just as you
would hope any juror would apply to
yourself or your loved one if they were
sitting in that chair
and do you think in the current
political climate that we're getting
closer to getting some real reform
well I'm optimistic I mean hearing for
the first time in my life criminal
justice reform talked about by both
parties
something is wrong when we're spending
more to lock people up than to help
educate them and people I think now are
starting to push back people are through
cell phone videos or seeing that
police-citizen encounters aren't always
what they were told you know there's a
lot of racial disparity that's coming to
the forefront so you know there's a
younger generation who is waking up and
needs to be invested and taking
ownership in their system people have to
say enough is enough I'm taking back my
system and I want it to be fair jerry
buting thank you so much you're welcome
talking with me
you're very welcome for recent TV I'm
Justin Monticello